well
hello there uh this is danielle with you
again
thank you for being here for another
down the middle
where we try and get straight to the
source of
all of the information that you need
whether we're talking about economics
pandemics or the financial markets today
i am
blown away to have william white i call
him bill
with us he is a senior fellow at the cd
howe institute
in toronto canada uh but that doesn't
begin
to if we had an hour and a half we could
get all the way through his cv
uh but suffice it to say he is a
canadian
born and started off at the bank of
england in 1969
but we're going to start off by asking
bill
where is kenora what is kenora and what
what sent you a foot to the university
of manchester so start out in the
beginning if you would mind bill and
welcome thank you for being here
well thank you very much for inviting me
it's a and it's a pleasure to see you
again
um yeah kenora is a small town 10
000 people um about 300 miles north of
minneapolis
um next big town west is
120 miles away next big town east is 300
miles away
so we were we were right up there and um
i i i actually was was orphaned at an
early age and i went to live with my
uncle
who actually had a very good job at the
local paper mill
at a time when the paper mill was really
the sort of the heart of
uh the heart of the town certainly um
but having said that uh we didn't have
an awful lot of money
i mean uh it was it was a a very
comfortable upbringing
but we didn't have all that much money
so when it came time to go to university
i had to do the proverbial follow the
money so i got a scholarship to go
to uh the university of windsor which in
those days was known as assumption
university because it was run
by the brazilian fathers who i think
have got a
a link to texas as well
and then when i finished my
undergraduate degree it was follow the
money again so i got a commonwealth
scholarship and i went to the university
of manchester
um so that's how 1957
more or less 1967 when you first earlier
than that i think about 1965
i think yeah it was yeah in 1965.
so i mean i i can't imagine i mean we
you know bill we've just come through i
think what we could all agree
is a monumental turning
event in world history
but you set foot into
england when it was at the epicenter
of a cultural revolution the likes of
which we haven't seen really
since then take what what was it like i
mean you were
you were there with the beatles
well um i arrived i think in september
of 65
and i was told that the stones had
actually performed
at the student refectory in march so i i
missed them
but it goes to show how given given how
much
it costs for a ticket to see them now it
uh
it shows you that i was right in there
at the uh at the beginning with the
you know when they had humble roots oh i
i'll tell you bill
uh growing up as i did uh my my father
raised me on beethoven the beatles and
the rolling stones
uh and and you know it was it was a
broad mix
and then the steppenwolf albums they
would always scare me that the album
covers
um that always takes me back but i
at the end of the day the stones are my
band sympathy for the devil's my
favorite song
in the entire world and
i incorrectly told my husband that
seeing the rolling stones live was on my
bucket list
well after keith richards should be in
front of people so i had the second row
seats and it was so close to me i said
to myself
if i see the rolling stones again live i
need to be further back
but if absolutely great music but but
i mean that was was was it as tumultuous
a time
in england as it was in the united
states or was that more
centric to the civil rights movement and
what was happening
was there any spillover effect the way
there is today when you see
one spring revolution become the dawn of
what appears to be a domino that you
know that goes all around the world or
was it really contained to the united
states
oh i don't think it was contained to the
united states i mean uh you remember
back in 68
i think there was a huge uh uprisings in
france and in germany
uh and in the uk to be honest the only
thing that i can
remember of course was ongoing protests
against the vietnam war of course
uh and i can remember sort of barricades
around the u.s
embassy and uh and of course
anti-apartheid was another big thing i
um
i can remember participating in a
demonstration against the
springboks i think you'd come to to play
rugby in the
in in britain and all i can remember
from that particular occasion was just
how big
those horses are you know those police
horses oh yes
they're certainly useful in intimidating
a crowd that's for sure
but no i think there was not the same
degree
of contagion if you want to call it that
then as there is today but there was
still a very substantial amount of it
uh we were all plugged into concern
about the vietnam war in particular
right well and you know there again
there are so many parallels that can be
drawn today
which which we'll get to uh but i'm
curious why central banking because
right you'd finished your studies
uh you you started off at the bank of
england uh
you you chose to go that route as
opposed to the private sector
uh what drew you to to the central bank
and tell us a little bit about
charles goodhart well you know it's a
it's a bit
what drew me to central banking
i had a lot of job offers actually from
the private sector and i sometimes
speculate on how life would have worked
out if i'd joined them in those early
days
some quite successful firms but i guess
i was brought up
with a very strong sense of public
purpose
and uh my uncle and all of my family
members thought about
uh being in public service as being
something very worthwhile to do
and uh so in the end when i had to make
the decision i
i chose to to go into the public sector
why central banking um that
i think was just um sort of serendipity
in a way
when i first went to university um i
wanted to go into politics
i always been very interested in
politics and i guess like any young man
i thought i was going to become prime
minister
but the university that i got the
scholarship to didn't have
a degree in politics they only had a
joint degree in politics and
economics economics and political
science
and so i did it and then under the force
of certain teachers
i just got drawn more and more to
to macro macroeconomics and so when i
went to do my phd in manchester that was
what i chose to do
and um interestingly enough in the uk in
those days there were no courses for a
phd
you did courses at the ema level but for
the phd it was just
a thesis so um i had to make a choice
and
um on the basis of the availability of
data because i was getting very
interested in econometrics
uh on the basis of the availability of
data
i started to get into monetary economics
and then one thing led to another
and my thesis was actually was called
the authorities
in the gilt hedge market the uk
guildhedge market
and it was called the authorities
because nobody really knew
in those days who was in charge was it
the bank of england or was it really the
treasury
and of course we're going back to that
kind of world too i think
oh we are indeed the parallels are
striking right now
yeah it's very very interesting so
anyway that's what i did my thesis on
and uh then i got this job offer from
the bank of england and uh
and i took it and that's when i had the
opportunity to meet charles goodhart
who um charles was about maybe five
years
or maybe a bit more eight ten years
older than me
and he was there as a full-time employee
but
i think he was an advisor of some sort
and he
basically oversaw the the group that i
was in
so um and we we've kept up a kind of
lifetime
lifetime friendship really um
so anyway that's the thing it seems like
his tv is actually
more extensive and broad than yours
oh oh yes absolutely absolutely um
now he has had the advantage of course
of being a professor and being able to
to work with all sorts of different
students
and so i think that draws you somebody
has an interesting thesis topic
and then you say well i'll oversee that
and of course the
the the the reason why they do it
sometimes is because they don't know
anything about it
and they think they're going to learn
more from the student and the students
can learn from them
so i suspect that's how charles got into
many of the things but he's got a huge
portfolio of uh
of interests and talents well computing
his most recent book about
uh the demographic reversal well and
and that to me bill the reason i've
always been drawn to you there
uh robert schiller uh i i can't even
name on one hand
uh phds who will take my phone calls so
given given how critical i've been
uh of academics in central banking
because so many and this was interesting
my mentor harvey rosenblum
at the dallas fed uh after after 40
years in central banking
he looked back and uh i was
i was kind of his his final chapter if
you will and i broke the
with the orthodoxy and he was very proud
of that but he said you know danielle
looking back
40 years later my one regret is
that that so many of the phds in the
research department who i've worked with
over the years
haven't broadened out the scope of their
studies since
they wrote their dissertations and they
they've spent the entirety of their
career
expanding upon the one subject but not
necessarily
helping in terms of guiding the future
of monetary policy so
i'm sharing that with you uh but but i
have the deepest respect because you've
kept an open mind
throughout your entire career which i
think is one
of the the failings of so many central
bankers
that aren't able to to break from
what their line of thinking has been um
i'm gonna switch gears for just a minute
1969 the cover of businessweek
magazine uh said the death of equities
1969 uh the unemployment rate in the
united states was
three and a half percent very very low
we didn't revisit it until 2020.
so what was that environment like
because it would seem to be
in stocks went into this period where
they were shunned by
investors eventually we get to 1981
where that's the last time that we even
had a single digit price to earnings
ratio
on on the s p 500 on the broadest stock
market index in the world
but there was this period from 1969
until 1981 where
where securities were shunned investing
was looked at differently
and inflation was actually something
that we could speak about
in practice as opposed to being just
purely in theory
so walk me through that decade
well i i think the defining element in
in in the period of course was was
inflation
and uh it was very much uh too much of a
good thing
perhaps as we might say today um
i think one of the big sort of factors
was
um the the the joint pursuit in the
united states of both
the war and the great society um
and all of this took a toll in terms of
government spending
and i know that in canada we sort of
were very concerned about the rising
inflation in the united states at the
end of the 1960s and going into the
1970s
and that's when we cut the link we
decided to go off the fixed exchange
rate system and to float
as a means of trying to insulate
ourselves
um it worked in part but certainly not
entirely because we wound up as indeed
did
almost all of the world to varying
degrees with a much higher level of
inflation
and really the battle against that
as as you know um really took us to the
volcker years in 1981 1982
where i can say from a personal
perspective i was
displeased and having to roll over my
mortgage at 22
oh my gosh um so it was a totally
totally different world
and in a sense there are some parallels
to today
because the the the oil
shock which people talk about in 1970
was in 1974 i think
74 the embargo yes yeah yeah in 1974 and
people
think about it as the the
the oil price shot but i have to say
that there was so much inflation
going on everywhere else that in a
certain sense the oil price increase was
really just a regulated price
by by opec kept catching up with the
higher prices elsewhere
so it was an under underlying oil it was
a fiscal monetary problem it wasn't an
oil
price problem but when the oil price
thing kicked in
my recollection was that the first
response
was basically it being a supply shock it
was both pushing up prices and pushing
down employment and so the reaction was
to try to mitigate the the costs on the
employment side
and to sort of keep the monetary spigots
open
and then that turned into such an
accelerating rate of inflation
as indeed milton friedman and ed phelps
and others had
suggested earlier would be the case that
they had to sort of turn around and
re-evaluate
and basically say it's better
to lean against the inflationary side of
things as opposed to the
unemployment side of things and indeed
that's what
paul volcker did um in 1982
and as they say the along with my 22
[Music]
mortgage they say the rest is history
well the rest may be history but bill i
could go back
and edit the conversation we just had
and substitute in pandemic induced
supply chain
shock trade war that preceded its supply
chain
shock an overemphasis uh
in monetary policy unemployment uh
government spending going through the
roof
to address it it's i i'm trying to go
through
the number of things that went through
my mind
that we're staring at today
that you just described from 40 years
ago as we come
on the 40-year anniversary of really the
last time we had to worry about those
skyrocketing mortgage rates it's
absolutely
it's just uncanny well there
is um
[Music]
also a great big difference
and the difference is that there has
been
a consistent secular increase in debt
levels
first as a ratio of gdp
first in the advanced market economies
but now increasingly in the emerging
markets
and so whatever happens on the inflation
front
is now going to confront
an economy that in a certain sense has
a built-in comorbidity you know like the
pandemic
yes there's there's
stresses in the underlying system
uh that will be stressed still further
should there be a resurgence of
inflation and should
the monetary authorities choose and
that's an interesting question
choose to lean against it so
um i think the future is likely to be
fairly
turbulent on that front i i fear before
before we go there um i want to stay
with paul volcker because you were you
were witness
to a changing of the guards
there was one individual who
truly didn't care about what the
financial markets made
of the policy and wall street was not
his concern he was replaced by somebody
who every morning by 7 30 a.m
had a stock market briefing from the
overnight trading on his desk
and whose focal point was very much
the financial markets and very much how
he was perceived
by politicians um
talk to me about that one
shift in terms of the perspective
of the leader of the most important
central bank
in the world and how that
changed basically the entire direction
of where monetary policy was going
for the next 25 years
well i think that's um a perceptive and
unfortunate observation because
i think you you can trace today's
problems back
at least as far as the greenspan put
and i know george soros and and some
others would
would trace it back even further to
the kind of um
accommodation um and forbearance in
financial markets going back to the
1980s
you know having to deal with the latin
american and the post
post-energy problems with with debt
uh but certainly starting in 1987 i i do
remember when i was at the bank of
canada
uh because we we basically did the same
thing as as they did in the states
but my recollection was that you you
you had the stock market crash remember
in was in may of 1987
and there was just a a massive easing of
monetary policy almost worldwide
but i think the states and i could i beg
to be corrected on this but i think that
the
the states tended to be more
accommodating for a longer period of
time
than did many other countries but in any
event that that
sort of was the beginning of it there
was a problem and the answer was easy
monetary policy
and then of course we had exactly the
same thing in 1990 when you had the
the the the property you know the s l's
and all that kind of stuff and
the tequila crisis and orange county
went bankrupt in 1994 there were two
two events that rocked the bond market
that one year
and then there was the southeast asia
crisis in 95
and then um
uh long-term credit in 98.
and that was
i'm going to interrupt you with
long-term capital management because
i'll go back to harvey rosenbloom
from the perspective of somebody inside
the fed he was at he was in chicago
then that was
the turning point that he saw was
long-term capital management
and alan greenspan being very jp
morgan-esque
if you will gathering the biggest
bankers in america into a room and
asking them all to write a check to bail
out an academic run hedge fund that
threatened to unleash systemic risk but
it's interesting that that the two of us
see it as being more 1987.
alan greenspan this is a matter of
public record he
he allowed the new york markets desk to
leak information about fed injections of
liquidity
prior to those daily moves in
the weeks and months that followed the
crash of 1987.
so it started way back when but from the
perspective from the perspective of a
central banker
it was always intriguing to me that they
saw the line in the sand
as long-term capital management yeah
yeah well that
um that that that doesn't surprise me
um i think you can make you could you
can make a case for a lot of starting
dates but i think the important thing to
keep in mind
is that we have had for at least about
30 years
a recurrent tendency to use monetary
policy as the weapon of choice
whenever there has been a downturn or a
threatened downturn
and i am sure that
individual people had their motives for
doing what they did
but in the background there's always the
academics are you know as kane said
you're always sort of marching to the
tune of some academic scribbler
and the the the the view coming out of
the universities
was that fiscal policy had to be was it
timely targeted and temporary
those things couldn't be done in a
practical way
so therefore fiscal was no longer on the
cards as part of the stabilizing
mechanism
so in a way and you can say this it's in
spades since the
since the great financial contraction
but monetary policy was left as the only
game in town
and it was used recurrently and the
problem with it
is as i see it anyway is that there's a
kind of fundamental
intertemporal inconsistency and what i
mean by that
is that you can use monetary policy once
you know to stimulate the economy and it
works
but in part it works through stimulating
spending
which is unproductive and so what that
means is that the debts that have been
built
up under the influence of the low
interest rates
in some fundamental way are becoming
less serviceable
because the underlying investment is not
productive in fact much of the
underlying spending was consumption
right and if you go on and on and on
what you see is that the debts just keep
piling on and piling on
and every time you use monetary stimulus
it works
but it works less effectively so that it
has to be done even more vigorously than
it was done before
the law of diminishing returns yeah and
so the logic of it tells you that at a
certain point
you're going to get to a stage where
that monetary easing is not going to
work at all
and it is interesting that over the
course of the last five
six years or so uh central bankers
uh almost everywhere have been saying
in a quiet kind of way well we probably
need more help from fiscal policy
and then since the the the the pandemic
occurred of course
uh those sort of quiet murmurs have
turned into loud shouts
about we just can't do anymore we need
help
now the second thing about all of this
monetary easing
in in addition to its increasing
ineffectiveness
is the problem of what i call the
unintended consequences
and so this brings us back to i think
what you were getting at earlier about
the greenspan
put and everything else that followed
but a lot of the excesses
are occurring in the financial markets
and we're seeing this i mean absolutely
in spades today i mean it's
extraordinary what's going on in the
financial markets but in the equity
market in particular but
but anyway this is the the end of a very
very long line
and i've been trying over the course of
the years to
to point out the fact that these
unintended consequences
are getting um more and more
um difficult to deal with but
to no greater veil i mean even even the
last couple of days i think chairman
powell has said that
he's uh he's got to keep his eye on the
inflation ball
and inflation's too low and somebody
else has got to worry about wall street
um but that's how can one say
that sort of to me implies
against the backdrop of all the the puts
against
falls in the prices of financial assets
basically says that wall street can do
whatever it wants as long as the prices
are going up
exactly but somehow there's a backstop
if the prices go down
and um that's that's not
so helpful i i wrote a piece when i was
at the bis in 2004 i think
and it was called are changes in
financial structure
affecting safety nets and you know
if i do say so myself it was pretty
prescient because
the focus was on the increased use of
market-based finance as opposed to
institution based in intermediation
and the basic idea was that in the end
the central banks would wind up
as market makers of a last resort
as opposed to lenders of lost last
resort
and that's exactly where in fact we have
wound up
and i think it's actually pretty
dangerous
so bill you brought up the word
productivity the idea of productivity
and i don't think that there
is before we get to where we are today
and where we're headed
i don't think that there's a deep enough
appreciation for
two economic cycles two very very
long economic cycles in a row that were
at their root non-productive you had
40 of americans in 2005 2006
either directly or indirectly employed
in residential real estate
in the cycle that we've just come
through post great financial crisis
it became all about finance and balance
sheet
maneuvering and the financial sector
became
an overly large portion of
the economy but we weren't actually
making anything and
we look back at fixed stock investment
and
and we say well where is it why you know
why why are we
losing the war to china
and a lot of it comes down to good
old-fashioned
they're making widgets i mean they might
be artificial intelligence widgets
they're the next generation of widgets
but they're making something but i don't
think people appreciate
because they see they perceive these
great
long recoveries these great long
expansions of being
indicative of some kind of success
on the part of monetary policy makers
but
there is something to be said and i hate
to put you in this position
but there's something to be said for the
value
of a recession from time to time
oh sure i mean i um i i entirely agree
with you
it's a kind of shumpitarian kind of idea
uh that um you need to have downturns as
it were to burn away the underbrush i
mean
a good a good analogy is forest fires
sure you know
and yellowstone which uh i guess in the
1980s sort of burned down
50 of it and the reason why apparently
was
that sometime in the 1930s they decided
to
start putting out all the fires whereas
previously they'd only put out
fires caused by campers and they'd let
the natural fires
burn well they changed that policy
they put out all the fires and then by
1980 the underbrush had grown so thick
that when the fire started they couldn't
put it out
and that's that's by analogy the kind of
problem we have that
if you don't have some kind of a
cleansing on a regular basis
you will get a much bigger cleansing at
the end
and i mean i've argued with fed
colleagues
when i was at the bis and they would say
but look at the integral of all the
extra growth that you got during the
good years
was arguably greater than the losses
from the conflagration right at the end
i said well that's possible but the
other
side of it is and this goes back to
political economy not just the economics
is that the political fabric can stand
little downturns okay and in certain
ways
almost welcomes it the political fabric
comes under great stress
when you've got a really big downturn
and we've got all sorts of evidence on
that now there's there's quite a
quite an academic literature about this
stuff going back
really over a 100 years the big
downturns
economic downturns always elicit
a political cost and that's
in a certain sense what i'm what i was
worried about in 2008
and i'm worried about even more now
because the pandemic has
has sharply worsened uh many of the
economic problems faced particularly by
poorer people and people of color and so
that's um we we do need these little
downturns i think
and uh monetary policy has actually been
pretty resolutely against
doing that um and
in how can one say that
there is there is a problem
paul volcker's made made this point
repeatedly in in
in his lifetime that that a central bank
can only do stuff
that the public allows it to do um
and when he did what he did in 81 and 82
he saw clearly
that the public was fed up with high
inflation and knowing it was going to go
even higher
and they were prepared to do so to allow
some tough things to deal with it
um so i um
yeah i i i do get worried that
um we've gotten ourselves into a bad
place
can i say more broadly though about the
sort of productivity thing that you
raised earlier
yes that i think one of the things that
has been neglected
along with the unintended consequences
of easy money
for the financial markets okay and like
well you know all this stuff better than
i do all of the imbalances and the
very odd things that are going on with
respect to flash crashes and market
anomalies and
elevated asset price okay but in
addition to all of that there's another
whole set of unintended consequences
which go back to
productivity and this this is basically
hayek back in the 1930s talking about
mal investments and when you think about
the economy sort of from an evolutionary
perspective
you know schmitterian perspective if you
want
you know we advance over time through
the dynamic
gains okay of an evolutionary process
in which new firms come in and
with new ideas and and new ways of doing
things
and the old firms go out because they
can't
because he can't because they haven't
made the cut they're not productive
they're not efficient they're not
profitable they're not job creators
they're just deadwood
they have to go and um the problem at
the moment as it seems to me
is that easy money creates problems both
with respect to new entries
and with respect to zombie old companies
and there's a growing literature on this
so when you think about the new
entries well let's start with the
zombies
that if you've got banks and other
providers of finance who
are prepared to continue financing
old firms that
ought to go the way of all flesh then
those providers of finance are not only
keeping these guys in alive
who are then dragging down the
productive firms into the grave with
them
because they're keeping up the price of
factor inputs that otherwise would be
cheaper for the new firms and in
addition
the new firms don't really get a look in
to the providers of credit that are
preoccupied with zombies
because those firms are so concerned
about their own
future and the future of the zombies
that they're not going to give
loans to guys in garages that have got
nothing but good ideas and no collateral
so there's a real problem on that front
and with respect to the new firms the
other aspect of it in addition to the
influence of the zombies keeping out new
firms
is that a lot of money is being directed
as you know through venture capital and
and and and through other other means
to firms everybody's betting on the
unicorns right
and the ubers and the netflixs and the
you know and and
we're seeing it today i mean in the in
the in the equity market in a
in a crazy kind of kind of way
but if you've got all of those real
resources sort of going into
ventures that nine tenths of them will
never
pay off then there's an awful lot of
investment that might have been used
more productively that just simply has
been
malinvested so
i i'm i'm not not suggesting
that everything that the central bankers
have done has been
uh inappropriate uh certainly in terms
of the downturn
the the the meltdown in the financial
markets you know in 2008 and
and more recently um
[Music]
they had to step in to do what they did
but what worries me is that
they have failed to see that
acting to to mitigate a financial crisis
is a very different you know a crisis by
definition has a beginning and an end
it's just short short
right and it doesn't just that doesn't
justify
following more or less the same kind of
easy money policies for a decade or more
right which is where we seem to have got
to you stay in defcon one
indefinitely it would seem you know well
i'm curious because you have a much more
international
focus and also because you live in
canada
uh it seemed like when the subprime
crisis was brewing
in the united states that the world
became
acutely sensitive to the dangers of a
housing bubble
and looking back 12 years
you see many housing bubbles in
throughout the developed economy
and you know that they end not just
in recession but in balance sheet
recession
but nobody speaks of what's happening
very few people talk about
canada and australia and norway even
germany now
very few people talk about the fact that
that in
the background we have many housing
bubbles
that have been inflating for years and
years and years
and what the implications are for
a multitude of balance sheet recessions
to occur at one time
absolutely and i i know
you know people
[Music]
said that canada the nordics
many other countries sort of got through
the great financial contraction without
any really
deep contraction and in a sense
that that is true but the downside of it
again sort of talking about ultra easy
monetary policy
is that under the influence of very low
rates
provided by the big guys of whom the fed
is the biggest of all
everybody else had relatively easy
monetary policies too
and so what has happened in a place like
canada and you see the same thing in the
nordics you know denmark sweden norway
is that household debt under the
influence of those very low interest
rates household debt has risen to
unprecedented levels the price's
price of housing has risen to
unprecedented levels
and it is a real source of concern for
central banks in many of these countries
but of course the the problem is
if they let's say canada
decided to tighten up because they were
worried about household debt and house
prices
to tighten credit conditions along those
lines
uh their currencies would sharply
appreciate
with big implications for employment and
and stuff elsewhere so in in a sense
it is truly an international problem
or to turn the whole thing around the
fed is basically
setting the interest rate structure for
the world because the dollar is still
the sort of central currency
right the united states in a sense quite
rightly
is saying well we have to focus on
things that are important to people in
the united states and indeed that's what
fed legislation says they must do but
from the perspective of
the global economy it implies
that the person who
really is in charge is taking no
responsibility
for the global economy
there's we we i think we need we need
reform of the international monetary
nun system and that's another one of
these things like
uh debt restructuring um
alternative monetary systems that nobody
really
really wants to talk about well that's
that that's kind of what happens when
there's
nothing else to talk about which is why
nobody wants to talk about
it nobody wants to go there so to speak
but you know when you talk about
the interconnectivity and how
central banking is now kind of a
universal approach
easy monetary policy everywhere
it has it has seeped into the emerging
markets
as you've recognized and it is not
purely
a sovereign phenomena you see that the
corporate debt markets
in the emerging markets have really
exploded and taken off in the last
decade
so it's not a pure imf
angle into any given country i think
post pandemic the the imf was involved
with 84 or 80
some ungodly number of countries uh were
being assisted by the imf but i i think
that there's an under appreciation for
the capital market structure that has
blossomed
to too great of an extent beyond just
sovereign debt in a lot of these
countries
and that makes that that makes the
sensitivity to
fed policy even higher
absolutely and um this is something that
the bis
has been going on about for for ages and
ages and i i certainly have been going
on about it as well
which is there has been really a a
massive increase in indebtedness
in uh emerging market countries and uh
a lot of it has been in the form of
issuance of corporate debt
and corporate debt in dollars when the
people issuing it are not actually
earning dollars so you can see there's a
there's a vulnerability there both to
the change in the
value of the dollar which then makes
dollar based debt
still harder to service okay and it also
exposes them to liquidity problems
because debt has to be rolled over in
dollars
right and um when you think about 2008
you were referring earlier on to the
housing you know the subprime crisis in
the states
i think there's a growing appreciation
and again the bis wrote a lot about this
back in 2010
2011 that it really shouldn't be called
the sort of subprime crisis
it really ought to be called the
transatlantic banking crisis
because the thing that was really most
remarkable about it was
all of these european banks who were
sort of
long us dollar assets uh
on the basis of borrowing in dollars and
then the
sources of money dried up and that's
when the fed had to come in with the
swap lines and all that kind of stuff
well
similar kind of problem here these
currency mismatch problems
are always a recipe for
for trouble ahead and clearly in the
emerging market economies
um it's it's not just the the size
of the debts that have been building up
but also the character
of those debts and both of them i think
are are dangerous
the fund said even before the pandemic
you know i think it was the um
the what is it the finance global
financial stability report of october
2019 right
the fund said then that 40 percent of
all the low-income countries
uh were already in distress or close to
distress
on the debt front and of course the
renewed access recently
okay as people search for yield against
the backdrop of very very low interest
rates
there's been a massive inflow of funds
into emerging markets
and um a lot of people are
you know the ones that have been
borrowing uh they say we've got
we've got access what's the problem but
of course as
any prudent man or woman would recognize
is you got access today but you might
not have access tomorrow and that's when
the problems will emerge
and they've got and it's it's it's
something that is global in scope
that we can't quantify even at this
point but there is economic scarring
throughout the global economy and the
the real economies
of so many countries have been scarred
and we don't know what the other side
is going to look like we don't know how
long it's going to take to close
individual output gaps we just know that
they're enormous
and that as you point out we've just
kept throwing more debt at it
2020 was a year for the record books
for all time when it comes to debt and
flows
yeah it's the uh
absolutely and uh the the real worry
would be
that going forward uh that these
problems of debt accumulation and the
other imbalances and the effects on
productivity etc will
start to manifest themselves but
you know but is it
that old line from the u.s army
that when you're up to your bum and
alligators it's hard to remember you
came to drain the swell
oh um you know that um
you when you when you're confronted with
a really serious problem
as these downturns in 2008 and more
recently have been
[Music]
people have done what they've done
out of necessity and it's the right
thing to do
at the time the real problem is looking
forward
how do you try to redress the balance
starting from where you start from
okay and i'm suggesting it's unfortunate
that we have got to this place
after 20 or 30 years but we are where we
are
now the question is how do you get out
of it and i think on the fiscal side in
particular
um i think there is continuing room for
maneuver
on the fiscal side almost everywhere
[Music]
the question is how do you ensure that
that room for maneuver
is used productively
and that you can then withdraw in the
fullness of time
to make the situation more sustainable
again
and this is where you'll get back into
the politics because
as long as things are rolling along
you know the deficits are big the stock
of debt is rising
the interest rates stay low under the
influence of the central banks
there's no problem um
well my worry would be that
people will not foresee the fact
that the potential problems are becoming
more grave even as things look perfectly
fine on the surface today
and that they won't take the steps
necessary to deal with the problems that
will be emerging tomorrow
and um i was just watching something uh
yesterday uh
carmen reinhardt and ken rogoff talking
about debt restructuring in emerging
markets
and saying that this is one of the
problems with emerging markets
governments in emerging markets is that
as long as the money's rolling in
there's not much of a tendency to say
there's a problem
and then they always get caught short
by a big crisis and the need to
restructure
and unfortunately the need to
which seems to be increasingly
disorderly
um they never get ahead of it and
uh since this is a kind of human
psychological propensity
i have no doubt that the people in the
advanced market countries will be
will be subject to the same kind of
problem you know as long as the good
times are
like chuck prince said right in a
different as long as the music's playing
you gotta keep dancing you gotta get up
and dance
so you know bill it's it's interesting
that you mentioned
october 2019 and a recognition that
there was a serious problem i mean i
remember one morning you would wake up
and turkey would be blowing up and the
next day you would wake up in argentina
would be going down the pipe
um but people forget that
2019 saw a full year contraction
in global trade you don't typically see
that unless you're in
headed towards a global recession and
the the tensions were starting to
percolate
in september of 2019
when the fed had to start stepping into
the market
because there were not ample enough
reserves in the u.s
banking system such that they had to
start
doing overnight repo operations in the
not qe
um i have this theory and and you can
you can call it bunk if you want
uh but because the market was beginning
to reject the idea of not qe
uh you know there had been there there
had been quantitative tightening and at
the same time with negative interest
rates imposed in other countries
there was a lot of money flowing into
the central the the federal reserve from
other central banks looking for yields
so they were looking to
park money at the fed at the same time
that currency and circulation was going
up
so when you took the money that was
flowing into the new york fed
from other central banks and when you
took the currency in circulation and you
added that together
it was of the same magnitude of
quantitative tightening
so the fed had inadvertently drained
twice as much from the system as they'd
want it to while they were raising
interest rates unlike any other central
bank
i was in brussels years ago and made a
speech that made me very unpopular at
the
at the eu and i said that mario draghi
would never be able to raise interest
rates before europe went into another
recession
and i was shown where the airport was
and and how i could leave and and they
didn't
but my point is heading into 2020
because the size of the not qe was
getting to be so enormous
and because it looked like counterparty
risk and
credit risk was becoming more of an
issue the fed needed to launch
real qe they needed a reason to flood
the system
with reserves but they didn't have it
because
theoretically we were still in a very
slow
expansion mode and so
i heretically say that the fed needed a
black swan
they needed an event there's no way you
you know central banks as well as i do
bill you you've worked in central
banking much longer i was there for nine
years but i can tell you
you don't roll out with shock and awe on
march the 23rd with that coordinated and
intricate and
detailed of a program unless you had
that pre-packaged and ready to go
in the event of a black swan so
i'm this this big diatribe is leading up
to
the idea and the sense that i'm getting
in markets right now
that we don't have a decade in front of
us
we don't have another long period of
recovery
and debt build that we once did
the confluence of factors is
such that what we're seeing markets are
behaving very irrationally today
as if a decade has gone by
since the pandemic hit and i feel like
we're in this time compression chamber
and i think you can share some insights
about
why things are happening as quickly as
they are
when you consider the confluence
of factors which you cover in a new
paper
well um that's a very uh
deep deep question i i certainly i've
been on record as saying for a couple of
years at least that uh
the economy global economy was an
accident waiting to happen
and what the trigger would be i had
absolutely no idea
it turns out the trigger for the
downturn was the pandemic
which um certainly no economists were
were contemplating
[Music]
so this thing was going to happen in any
event
and um so it's happened in the
particular way that it has
um the question is where do we go from
here
um i think you're right that there has
been a kind of
compression um
of anticipations
one of the things i mean i think we
talked about this a little bit earlier
on about inflation is inflation coming
back
and one might say well yeah it'll come
back and but it'll take a it'll take
quite a while and first of all we'll
have a disinflationary period and then
maybe we'll get to inflation
but as you know i mean the break-even
yields are indicating that the market's
already expecting
inflation to rise above two percent and
that could shift
really very quickly which again is a
kind of compression
um i don't actually know what to make of
what's happening on the equity front
uh where one might say you know in the
fullness of time equity prices should be
higher as the recovery
you know proceeds uh we've got the
markets doing
uh what they're doing which is quite
extraordinary really in terms of some of
these some of these uh
equity prices uh in spite of the fact
that the uh the imf for example in their
world economic outlet has just come out
and said
look at here's a benchmark okay like
we're going to get recovery in 21
22. but it's subject to enormous
uncertainties with respect to one two
three
four um what seems to be going on has
got
absolutely nothing to in the financial
markets got as far as i can tell nothing
to do with the real
prospect for economic recovery and
so um you can look at it that way that
sort of the longer term is just
you know it has been compressed into a
very short time period
but in any event um whatever it is that
is happening
even if it were to be at the end of a
three or four or five year period
i i think it's simply unsustainable
and i guess if i had to make a
prediction
i would i would think that a lot of the
stuff that we've seen
is going to reverse now whether it will
reverse tomorrow under the influence of
reddit and
you know all these retail traders and
whatever is another sort of totally
unknowable
unanswerable question because nobody's
ever seen this before
you know this is really totally this is
a real unintended consequence well but
bill by the same token
the the jay powell fed did not allow
markets to correct so
the process itself was arrested
in march of 2020 you never had
a full credit cycle we haven't had a
full bankruptcy cycle
you know but here's the point you're
going back to what we were talking about
earlier on
once you've gotten off on a bad path
it becomes increasingly difficult to get
off the path
until and the path gets narrower and
narrower
and so we're now at a point where
the bis have been talking about this for
years where we're caught in the debt
trap we've allowed these debts to get to
such a level
that we can't tighten up for fear of
creating the crisis that we all want to
avoid
however you know thinking about all
those triple b's and ratings changes and
all this kind of stuff so you're caught
in the debt trap you can't raise rates
but you can't leave rates where they are
because you're
observing the fact that these very low
rates are enticing people
to issue still more of the debt that's
the basis of the problem
right so you're sort of stuck and
what i've been saying and
i hope it's not too late to do it
not just me i mean working party three
at the oecd
the imf the group of 30.
people have been saying for ages and
ages all of our debt restructuring
procedures are inadequate
we need to get out of this debt problem
we are going to need debt restructuring
a lot of this debt will not be serviced
now the question is
how are you going to do that and
one answer is you know the old english
line
handicap and the comic strips can't pay
won't pay
which is just disorderly and then
everybody's there fighting for the
scraps and
countries are in enormous difficulty or
alternatively you can have procedures in
place
whereby people know how to identify
debts that are not serviceable then the
clock stops
restructuring takes place in an orderly
way people absorb their losses and move
on
but we're far from that's sort of what's
needed but we're far from it
and i guess in the background we have
several other horsemen of the apocalypse
at work some of whom benefit from
maintaining the disorder
yes well this is um this is
this is a real problem
in the sense that it isn't just the debt
problem that we're facing i mean you're
absolutely right on that
so we have this economic problem um
compounded by the fact that debt looked
sorry not debt but global growth looks
likely to be
inherently slower going forward than it
has been in the past
so we had a demographic dividend that in
sense we consumed as opposed to
invested right but we've got this
economic problem
and the difficulty that worries me is
that
to the degree that there is an economic
problem it creates political problems
and that impedes both the political will
and the capacity to deal with the other
problems and in addition to the economic
and political problems we've got the
environmental problems
i think people are becoming more and
more aware everywhere
that this climate change is not a hoax
that this is really happening that those
fires in california
and australia and siberia and northern
canada
etc etc these things are real they're
not fictional
so we got all of that and then you put
the pandemic on top of it
and the pandemic
again this is another example the
epidemiologists
were calling for much better preparation
for another crossover apparently i think
if you
go if you go back to aids i think we've
had seven identified crossovers viruses
from
animals to people or people since 2020.
so you know goodness me we should have
been better prepared
but we weren't and um
all in the interests of efficiency
didn't want all that excess capacity in
the hospitals
um so i mean this is another big thing
that's coming out of this
pandemic is the growing recognition that
um growth and efficiency isn't
everything
you know sustainability resilience
uh can you keep this show on the road
it's equally easy
but what you're describing is the
opposite of globalization
what you're describing is at its core
inflationary
if you think about it well it um
it could well be and
i guess i do
[Music]
i do worry that these underlying
inflationary forces you know the
demographics the
rolling back of globalization
the damage done by climate change the
costs to invest
in you know
[Music]
preserving uh land above water in
florida
these are all sort of in a way
unproductive um
and costly things that will push up
inflation
so i think that's the that's the big
danger going forward
and um
it might not happen for quite a long
period of time
alternatively it could be as i said
before talking about the break-even
yields that
you know and the rise in house prices
you know that what's going on here is
that people are starting to look over
their shoulder
and saying it's coming down the road so
therefore i'm going to protect myself by
buying real assets
or inflation protected assets and then
what you do is you're bringing tomorrow
into today and so it arrives much faster
than you would
than you would think um
there's some big issues big issues going
forward and
unfortunately i fear that with respect
to all of these things you know the debt
question the political question
you think about how close the election
was in the united states
uh indicating the degree of
dysfunction yeah at the political level
the absence of compromise
and you know when i think about politics
maybe i'm dead wrong here
but it seems to me that the whole point
of politics
is to establish the compromise
between divergent views and interests
that's what politics is all about we
can't
all have what everything we want and if
right
compromise if the political system can
no longer provide compromise
then we do not have a political system
and it's that kind of a vacuum
that the fascist and the extremist
forces just move into
so compromise is not something to be
discredited it's the essence of the
beast
anyway we've got all of these problems
that have to be dealt with at once
and um one
i mean when you look at some of the
things that you could say
are almost like sort of magic bullets
you know if you were if you're looking
at the list of what could be done ra
raising their reading my mind bill
raising the retirement age imposing a
significant
carbon tax getting rid of fuel subsidies
reducing tax expenditures you know tax
breaks for
people that have got vested interests
there's just so many things that you
could say well it's
just common sense it ought to be done
but i don't see much appetite for it
and that's the scary part no in fact it
seems that
you know i think when we look back on
2020 and 2021
uh we're going to say why why did the
government
spend all that money to no end
and where did where where did that
fiscal spending what did it create for
the long-term
economy uh bill again i i don't speak
with many central bankers so you're
you're absolutely the exception
and i admire you greatly uh when
when many central bankers are asked the
question
what will this ultimately look like the
idea
of a debt jubilee comes to the fore
and i'm wondering uh this is my last
question
but i'm wondering what your philosophy
is on
on the practicability of
a debt jubilee given
a lot of carmen reinhardt's work a lot
of a lot of what she has done in
focusing on
kind of i'm not going to put words in
her mouth but the quiet colonization
that china has has has
done over the past two decades and
the fact that there will be alliances if
you will
that there will be two sides that come
out of this
so with that as as a backdrop knowing
that there are two economic superpowers
what do you think the the capacity is in
the world if we had to go there
to have a debt jubilee resolve all of
the problems and
and hit hit a reset button if you will
well the the the first thing to remember
is that the the the debt
jubilee in the bible
it goes back to samaria and afterwards
um basically it was the king
and his cohorts who were all vastly rich
who were giving the dead jubilee and it
didn't really change their lifestyle
in the slightest you know it actually
was in their
best interest because they knew that if
they didn't do it
then you'd get a kind of social revolt
from the wage slaves
and they might lose everything okay so
we had a very small group of people who
could afford to do it
one of the complications today is that
[Music]
when you talk about a debt jubilee okay
or sort of wholesale debt forgiveness
you're basically saying we're going to
take it out of the pension funds
and this is not something that's going
to hit just a few rich people
it's going to hit everybody and that's a
real problem
and that's why you hear a lot of people
when you talk
to to them about the need for debt
restructuring
uh they'll they'll fall back and say
well you know we we can't do that
because we owe it to our
you know our pension pensioners and
policyholders and whatever so that
that's a real problem is that the
creditors now are very widespread
you know it's the old line from pogo we
have seen the enemy
and them as us and um
so that's a problem
another problem with respect to sort of
debt restructuring
and you've already referred to it is
china
and so we have a world in which for
example for sovereign debts
you know there are no agreed principles
on how you go about restructuring
sovereign debt
and there's great uncertainty
uh even against that backdrop there's
great uncertainty about
both the size of the chinese debts
and
[Music]
whether those debts are owned by private
sector entities or public sector
entities
right so should you be part of the paris
club or should you not be part of the
paris club
so there's just it's grown much more
complex particularly for the emerging
markets you know
there's a much wider range of creditors
now
some some of whom are ordinary people
really via
you know mutual funds and pension funds
and stuff like that
so i fear that in recent years it's a
the debt restructuring has actually
become more difficult
as opposed to less difficult
and i've only spoken now about as it
were the difficulties of doing
individual debt restructurings
the idea of a kind of jubilee that would
apply to all
debt i think is
i dare say as a non-starter now
the world is an odd place i uh there's
lots of things you don't predict that
actually happen
right a lot of things that you do
predict that don't happen
but uh my sense of it would be that
that's that's not a
that degree of orderliness in terms of
restructuring
is is not going to happen because we
don't even have any agreement at the
moment
on the criteria for doing it no
and you've actually i mean you've only
got 400 years of history
backing your theory because these tens
disorderly events tend to result in
a shift in the reserve currency status
inevitably
in the end and you know if again i'm
heavily influenced by carmen reinhardt's
work here but
i i don't see the elegance the ability
the wherewithal or even the desire to
pursue
such a an easy pathway out
because you're right back in the
biblical times
there were just a few people and they
all benefited and that's certainly not
the world
it was a mutually profitable trade
indeed indeed
well bill um look i'd like to come back
and do this again in a year and i hope
that
i hope that this intractability is
something that we're not
talking about a year from now you're one
of the few true
sober voices in in central banking and i
can't tell you how much
i admire your work but i i have one last
one
i always have one last burning question
so for me it is sympathy for the devil
what is your favorite rolling stone song
i think in the current circumstances i'd
have to say i
i ain't got no satisfaction
i love it bill that is fantastic
well thank you so much for your time i
really do appreciate it
i look forward to us getting vaccines
and and hopefully doing this next time
person to person i've got reason to be
in toronto so i will come find you
oh well i'm not i'm not hard to find i
i'm right downtown where all the museums
and the entertainment and the
restaurants and the cafes are one of the
cleanest downtowns in the world i love
your city
take good care bill thank you bye bye
now thank you very much
bye-bye well it's not often that i use
the word legend uh
but i hope that you enjoyed bill white
uh he's a longtime friend of mine i have
tremendous respect for him
i mean just to have that breadth of
knowledge
starting from the bank of england in
1969 and given how
critically important monetary policy is
watch it watch it again if you need to
and the extraordinary times in the
financial markets
that bill and i speak of if you want to
learn more about that
uh i i think the the interview that i
did recently here for down the middle
with peter atwater
that will resonate go back and watch
that as well because peter has so many
insights
about some of the crazy maniacal
you know chat room reddit short squeeze
all of those all of the buzzwords that
you're reading about today
peter's got some great insights about
what's driving that
and where we're headed so and remember
if you've not subscribed
please go and do that right now and i
will see you next time
for another episode of down the middle
thank you